you have a writer of many many romance
novels you have a cover model who is
trying to be the hero neither one of
them should be stuck in a jungle
seriously i've never gotten to shoot on
an island before i've never got to go to
the jungle a lot of this movie is out in
the elements and you really feel it
we're in the dominican republic this
gorgeous landscape we had a cast and
crew of 650 and you just really like
everyone living the dream to be here and
see how hard everybody works it's
amazing i'm gonna help you out a little
bit let's go don't do this get out of
there there we go
it's so nice to have a partner
that you feel as comfortable as i did
with channing you could pretty much give
us anything and we could make a 15 to 20
minute bit about it manscape
don't want to landscape you i didn't
bring my clippers we were glued at each
other's sides too heavy you're gonna
flip this thing like a cruise ship hold
on i can't breathe i'm good i'm not
breathing are you good my face the
fabulous daniel radcliffe
he's brilliant he's a brilliant actor
much more interesting things are
happening behind me right now i feel
like sorry
it's a great massive action adventure it
hits all those notes but it's also
genuinely very funny
honestly i thought we've got a cgi most
of this stuff
what was it like getting brad pitt
who
he showed up and was so game bulked up
for it did all these stunts it was
really awesome loretta sage i'm getting
you out of here
it was an amazing journey of many puzzle
pieces needing to come together to make
a film that you want to see in the
theaters
[Music]
[Applause]
it's such an adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you